life was going on good till I was doing
my school in college but the actual
struggle you know started out by
graduate because in a country like India
that I like lack so prior to its passing
out every year so it actually makes
difficult to get the job I thought my
studies and my marks would help me out
but that wasn't a scenario unfortunately
it was like very tough time for me but
the one thing that really helped me and
keeping going was my friends and my
family who was always there together and
they supported me very well I was always
interested in networking helping out
people it feels really nice when people
say that thanks for resolving my problem
but whereas when you do coding no one
appreciates you on the spot
working in a 24/7 and one it was
actually tough for me and I needed
someone who can actually support me well
so I started going about the central on
I got to know that they are the best
place which can provide you
certifications the trainers also
provided by the simply learned or
worthless simply learn actually makes
your learning really simple once you get
certified like I have done my ITIL as
well as CCNA it is going to get me
promoted which is obviously going to
make me more happy it's given me a
recognition as well as appreciation from
a lot of people and this will probably
make me grow faster so I'm expecting to
say for my company and I know I will
definitely get promoted so I'm very much
happy with that the starting point of
great success is for you to realize that
you are truly extraordinary I am for
asana
and the progeny of simply